PRIYANKA VERGADIA: When it
comes migrating to Google Cloud,
how do you build connectivity
between your on-premises
and Google Cloud environment?
How do you secure and
monitor your apps?
Well, stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Cloud Migration 101,
where we share migration tips
and tricks.
In the last episode, we learned
about resource hierarchies,
access control,
permissions using IAM,
and the four methods of
interacting with Google Cloud
services.
Today, let's address
some of the questions
from the engineering teams.
For this, let's get Kyle back.
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Hi, I'm Kyle.
Today, we are going to focus
on the three main questions
that the engineering
team will have
when planning a migration or
landing zone on Google Cloud.
One, how to connect the existing
infrastructure to Google Cloud.
Two, how to protect
the applications
to maximize security.
And three, how to know
when something goes wrong,
which is monitoring.
Let's start with networking.
Your existing
network architecture
and application
flow will determine
how you establish your
cloud network setup
and how your applications
communicate with your existing
services.
In Google Cloud, the
physical network layer
is virtualized using
software-defined networking.
You will deploy and
configure a network
in a virtual private
cloud, or VPC.
You can run VPCs across multiple
regions and multiple zones
within regions to support a
wide variety of architectures,
including backup and
disaster recovery needs.
You can also use a special
type of VPC called a shared VPC
to connect resources from
multiple Cloud projects
into a central VPC network.
Or you can use VPC
peering to connect
multiple VPCs across
many different projects
or organizations.
The next question is,
once you have a VPC,
how do we connect it to your on
premises existing environment?
There are three ways
that you can do this.
First, you can connect
over the public internet
using Cloud VPN.
Second, you can connect over a
private, SLA-backed, dedicated
high-speed connection
using Cloud Interconnect.
Or third, you can establish
a direct peering connection
with Google's Edge network.
Typically, you would
set up Cloud VPNs
for testing and development
or temporary connections,
and establish interconnects
for production environments
or to support the widespread
migration of your applications
to Google Cloud.
The next question that I
commonly hear from customers
is, I have a firewall
that currently secures
my entire corporate network.
How can I migrate this
firewall to Google Cloud?
The way that you
manage and maintain
the security of your
systems in Google Cloud
can be different
than when managing
an on-premises infrastructure.
We highly recommend you check
out the firewall and security
features available in your VPC.
Link below.
Google Cloud is designed to
support a zero trust security
model, which can now be
enabled at your organization
with our context-aware
security and access solutions.
As far as data is concerned,
Google Cloud encrypts your data
in transit and at rest.
You also have other options like
Cloud Key Management Service
and cloud hardware
security modules,
depending on your security
and regulatory requirements.
And there are a
variety of options
to secure your infrastructure,
networks, endpoints,
and applications.
Check out the links
below to learn more
about the specific benefits
of Google Cloud Security.
The next question
I usually get is,
how do my existing monitoring
tools work within Google Cloud?
If you are using any VMware
or software-based system,
you can always just lift
and shift it directly
to Google's Compute Engine
or Google Kubernetes Engine
and continue to use it
exactly as you do on-premises.
For workloads running
on Google Cloud,
you can use a fully
managed monitoring
and logging solution called
Cloud Monitoring and Cloud
Logging.
You can even export monitoring
and logging events easily
into BigQuery and run all
kinds of reporting and analysis
on them.
As an example, you can
move a workload to GCE,
run a new GKE cluster, and set
up some serverless functions
and have all of those
logs automatically sent
to Cloud Logging.
Priyanka, where you at?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
Let's wrap this up.
What did you learn today?
We learned about VPC
networks, connectivity options
between Google Cloud
and on-premises, as well
as Google Cloud Logging
and Cloud Monitoring.
Want more details?
Check out the entire
guide linked below,
and stay tuned for the
next episode, where
we will talk about billing,
governance, and quotas.
In the meantime,
like, subscribe,
and comment to let us know
what you want to learn
about cloud migrations.